today i'm judge jury and executioner
hope you're ready to unleash your inner
green monster because we got some new
details on the new she-hulk series
coming to disney plus and we're gonna
smash
our way through it right now on the
ketchup here we go a lot has been
happening with the slate of marvel
series that are heading to disney plus
including a release date push for falcon
in the winter soldier
and the first trailer for wand division
so check out our episode on that if you
haven't already
this is our home now and on the heels of
those shows will be more avenger-centric
ones like low-key and hawkeye along with
a few fresh
character intros in miss marvel and
she-hulk and thankfully because we
really need
all the distractions we can right now
the details on she-hulk are starting to
take
shape big green shape tatiana meslani
has been cast in the lead role of
jennifer walters aka
she-hulk and tatiana's best known for
her emmy-winning role on orphan black
and she also appears in the new hbo
series perry mason
it's hard to believe that you're the
right person for the job now when it
comes to tatiana's character
jennifer walters is a new york attorney
who happens to be the cousin of bruce
banner it's always the cousin and he
gives her some of his power during a
life-saving blood transfusion after she
was accidentally shot by mobsters
jen can definitely hulk out when she's
angry but she's also developed great
control over her
powers and she can manifest them much
differently than her cousin bruce
you know what i mean funny enough the
character was created by john buscema
and stanley back in 1980 when the
incredible hulk tv series was actually
quite popular
and fearful that the show's producer
kenneth johnson would beat them to the
punch marvel
rushed she-hulk to the comic book pages
now in the past
multiple she-hulk series have actually
been in development with no luck
not to mention a she-hulk film starring
brigitte nielsen i mean i would still
pay really good money to see that
good luck i hope after we can be friends
so now that kevin feige is finally
making she-hulk happen it seems like one
thing we can definitely expect from this
show
is humor now this is something we've
seen in various iterations of the comics
through the years including one where
she ends up working in the same building
as howard
the duck please make this happen and
doing their part to bring the funny will
be lead writer jessica gao
who has shows like rick and morty and
robot chicken on her resume plus
executive producer and the director of
the pilot cat koiro who has helm shows
like modern family
the mick and it's always sunny in philly
so when it comes to additional
characters we actually don't know much
yet but given the common she-hulk
premise of jessica working as an
attorney in new york we could see new
york city-based characters from now
cancelled netflix shows show up like
luke cage
daredevil and eventually jessica jones
wouldn't that be dope
of course like all the other new disney
plus series this will
also tie directly into the mcu most
likely coming at the end of phase four
perhaps sometime in late 2021
but i will believe this all when i see
it and don't worry friends we will keep
you posted
i'm a huge fan of the way you lose
control and turn into an enormous green
rage monster
alright friends it's time for us to kick
it over to you now how excited are you
for the new she-hulk series coming to
disney plus please smash your way into
the comments let us know all your
thoughts and feelings and also be on the
lookout for more information
on the upcoming wandavision and miss
marvel and
do not forget to check out our new
rotten tomatoes podcast it's called
rotten tomatoes is wrong a podcast from
rotten tomatoes
because fresher rotten is just the
beginning of the conversation and new
episodes drop every thursday so be sure
to subscribe to that
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit that subscribe button and
notification bell
and as always we can't thank you enough
for watching the ketchup my name is
perez and i hulk out when i get hangry
bye
[Music]